اهلا بكم في السودان لا يزال توتر قائما
بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطوم ومدينه مروي شماليا البلاد
بالاطراف الدوليه واقليميه ومحليه لاحتواء
التوتر اثر نشر الدعم السريع قوات بجوار
مطار مروي بالولايه الشماليه ويتهم الجيش
هذه القوات بارسال مزيد من التعزيزات الى
مدينه مروي حيث عزز الجيش قواته ايضا
كماثت صور تظهر وصول ارتال لاليات عسكريه
تابعه للدعم السريع الى الخرطوم قادمه من
الولايات خصوصا من دارفور هذا وكان الجيش
امهل الدعم السريع 24 ساعه انتهت فجر
اليوم لسحب قواته من محيط مطاري مروي
من جانبه قال اعلم قوه الدعم السريع ان
نائبه رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان محمد
حمدان حميتي عقد اجتماعا مشتركا عبر
الهاتف مع المبعوتين الامريكي والبريطاني
وايضا ان الرجيم بشان التطورات التي
يشهدها السودان والجهود المبذوله لاستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وتشكيل حكومه انتقاليه
مدنيه هذا واوضح اعلام الدعم السريع عن
حميدتي اكد حرصه على تعزيز الاستقرار ودعم
مسيره التحول الديمقراطي بالبلاد
وقد اعرب المبعوثون والممثلون الخاصون من
فرنسا والمانيا والنرويج وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
اعربوا عن قلقهم البالغ ازاء التصعيد بين
القوات السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
وقالوا ان ذلك يهدد بعرقله المفاوضات
لتشكيل حكومه الانتقاليه بقياده مدنيه
ودعا المبعوثون القاده العسكريين
والمدنيين في السودان لاتخاذ خطوات فعاله
للحد من التوترات وخفض التصعيد